en este vídeo quiero recordar por qué es
tan importante para hablar de ángulos
tanto en radiales como en grados y
también quiero que veas porque pi es un
valor fundamental al cual no le tenemos
que quitar el ojo de encima pero bueno
antes de eso me gustaría recordar que
significaba pin y pin por definición y
para poner por definición ponemos un
triple signo de igual si le podemos
llamar a esto así es un triple signo
igual porque estamos hablar de la
definición que es igual a la
circunferencia entre el diámetro es
decir esto es lo mismo que la longitud
de la circunferencia entre dos veces el
radio y justo de aquí sale una de las
fórmulas más importantes y más
indispensable que has visto en toda tu
vida si justo de aquí queremos despejar
a la longitud de circunferencia entonces
necesitamos pasar del otro lado este dos
pierden y va a pasar este dos pierde del
otro lado multiplicando entonces
llegaríamos a la igualdad 2 x r por pin
esto es igual a la longitud de la
circunferencia otra vez se te parezca
mucho más familiar la siguiente
expresión la longitud de la
circunferencia es igual a 2
radios o sosos cual es el plural de
radio es radios radio sos radio sos
ociosos
pero lo que sé es que esta expresión te
va a servir bastante y seguramente has
visto al inicio de tu carrera o miles de
veces y justo de esta idea es donde sale
cómo medimos a los ángulos en radiales y
todo esto es solamente un repaso así que
déjame dibujar te un mejor círculo como
este de aquí este va a ser mi eje de las
x perfecto y si yo quiero tomarme un
ángulo ahí me voy a tomar un ángulo
obvio para empezar este ángulo de aquí y
entonces yo defino este ángulo con el
nombre de teta y la forma en la que
definimos la medida de un ángulo cuando
hablamos de ángulos en radiales
estamos hablando de aquel ángulo que
está suspendido por un cierto arco de la
circunferencia
si hablamos de radiales entonces la
longitud del arco debe estar en medida
de radio sosos que bueno tal vez no sea
una palabra pero tú me entiendes por lo
tanto en este caso particular lo que sí
sabemos es que la longitud de la
circunferencia y esto es por definición
es igual a 2 pi
y entonces la longitud de este arco pues
va a ser un cuarto de la longitud de la
circunferencia entonces podríamos decir
que la longitud de este arco es pues de
longitud de la circunferencia lo cual es
dos pierden entre cuatro porque por
geometría básica estamos solamente
tomando un cuarto de la longitud total
por lo tanto si toda esta vale dos
pierden entonces la longitud de este
arco pues va a ser dos pies de entre
cuatro así déjeme ponerlo por acá la
longitud de este arco antes de definir
este ángulo va a ser igual a dos p r
entre cuatro espero que sí se vaya
entendiendo 2 p r entre 4 que por cierto
esto es lo mismo que pin medios por el
radio o si lo vemos en medida de radio
sosos entonces tendríamos pin medios
radios osos radios osos osos o lo que
sea que es esta palabra que tú me
entiendes que esta palabra por qué
porque si entonces el arco que se
extiende este ángulo tiene una longitud
de pi medios radios osos entonces este
ángulo tiene una
de pin medio raciones así de fácil
definimos la longitud en radiales
entonces para saber nosotros cuánto mide
un ángulo en radiales nos tenemos que
fijar cuál es la longitud del arco que
se extiende a ese ángulo en radios osos
buenos radio sólo tiene sentido creo que
es la dios radios entonces me van a
decir oye sal me estás diciendo mal como
se dice radio en plural radios osos no
es una palabra entonces perdón radios y
medios radios y entonces este ángulo
mide pi medios radiales y si nosotros
quisiéramos hacer otro ejemplo rápido
supongamos que yo me tomo ahora la
circunferencia entera yo quiero saber
cuál es la medida del ángulo en radiales
que está suspendido por una longitud del
arco que le da una vuelta entera a la
circunferencia pues entonces hay que
fijarnos qué es lo que pasa con la
longitud de la circunferencia y bueno
nosotros sabemos que darle una vuelta
completa al círculo en longitud de arco
es lo mismo que la circunferencia que es
lo mismo que dos paper o dicho en un
lenguaje más coloquial esto es lo mismo
que dos pi
adiós 2 para dios y entonces el ángulo
que está suspendido por la longitud de
la circunferencia es 2 y radiales pero
bueno realmente esta es una pequeña
parte del vídeo en la cual estamos
recordando cosas que ya sabemos con
geometría básica pero realmente yo lo
que quiero llegar es a la famosa fórmula
de hollar que por cierto yo creo que es
una de las cosas más hermosas que hay en
las matemáticas y en general en la vida
es una cosa impresionante que por cierto
ésta tiene que ver con las funciones
trigonométricas y si nosotros recordamos
a las funciones trigonométricas para
esto vamos a necesitar un círculo
unitario así que no va a tener un radio
de mil vamos a tener un radio de 1 y
déjame ponerlo por acá si yo aquí dibujo
a mi círculo unitario y entonces este es
mi radio que vale 1 yo puedo ver a
cualquier punto de esta circunferencia
de la siguiente manera si yo a este
punto le asoció un ángulo teta
entonces la coordenada en x de este
punto es el coste 9 theta y la
coordenada y en este punto va a ser el
seno
de teta y bueno esto no se ve muy claro
aquí pero si nosotros utilizamos los
colores para saber mejor lo que
caminamos en el eje de las 'íes' para
llegar a este punto es el c9 teta y lo
que caminamos en el eje de las equis
para llegar a este punto es el coseno de
teta así definimos cualquiera de todos
los puntos que estén en este círculo
trigonométrico y bueno inclusive con
esta misma idea podemos graficar una de
estas dos funciones trigonométricas y me
voy a tomar el seno sin embargo que
puedes utilizar lo mismo para el coseno
el seno de un ángulo como se ve su
gráfica entonces aquí tengo el eje de
las x que en este caso va a ser el eje
de los ángulos de teherán y en este caso
tenemos al elegir las 10 que es iguales
me gasté esperando que me poner aquí a
los ejes para que no nos confundamos
aquí tenemos el eje de las 10 en esta
gráfica
por otra parte aquí tenemos el eje de
las x también en esta misma gráfica y
entonces si nosotros nos regresamos a la
gráfica que queremos sacar a la gráfica
del seno detectan hay criticarnos en lo
siguiente si nosotros nos fijamos cuando
el ángulo vale cero grados o cero
radiales es más
voy a ver en radiantes aquí tenemos a
tetas radiales estamos graficando la
función y es igual a 9 teta y igualdad
seno de teta es la gráfica que me estoy
tomando aquí abajo no lo olvides
entonces cuando nosotros tenemos un
ángulo de cero radiales no subimos nada
entonces estamos en el punto inicial
después nosotros subimos hasta acá
cuando nosotros tenemos un ángulo de 90
grados o dicho de otra manera pin medios
radiales pigmentos radiales que quieran
tenerlo como por aquí aquí estamos con
medios radiales fíjate que el valor de
james subió hasta 1 porque recuerda que
el radio es 1 entonces subimos hasta 1
si nosotros nos seguimos por esta línea
llegamos a este punto de aquí es decir
tenemos un ángulo de 180 grados pero 180
grados es el mismo ángulo que tenemos al
recorrer la mitad de la circunferencia
por lo tanto speed radiales entonces
aquí tenemos el ángulo de pi radiales
llegamos otra vez al valor de 0 en game
date cuenta que en este punto de aquí no
avanzamos nada en ir no subimos nada y
después nos vamos a seguir sobre esta
misma circunferencia y llegamos hasta
este valor de aquí que son 270 grados
mejor lo podemos ver como tres medios
radiales el ángulo de tres primeros
radiales qué creés bajamos hasta el
valor de igual a menos uno y ojo no
olvides que teta está dado en radiales y
entonces y en este caso en tres primeros
radiales vale menos uno bajamos hasta el
valor de menos uno y vamos a ponerlo por
aquí aquí tenemos al menos uno y
entonces tenemos este punto de aquí y si
para finalizar nosotros subimos sobre
esta misma curva hasta llegar hasta este
punto de aquí que es darle una vuelta
entera de la circunferencia entonces
tenemos dos radiales
llegamos otra vez al valor de cero y
ahora si juntamos todos los puntos que
tenemos aquí vamos a encontrar la
gráfica de james igual al cero beteta
juntamos este punto con este punto y de
igual manera podemos graficar muchos más
puntos con este punto y llegaríamos a
esta forma que es la gráfica de y es
igual al seno del teta pero bueno esto
es también padre para recordar cómo se
grafican funciones trigonométricas
utilizando el círculo unitario pero
realmente yo lo que quiero llegar a este
vídeo es a comparar
o el valor de pi con otro número también
muy importante y entender qué relación
hay entre ellos dos pero antes de llegar
a este autor número mágico quiero
recordar la fórmula de oier que decía
que el elevado a la i por un ángulo teta
es igual al coste 9 t tramas y veces el
seno de teta esta fórmula es bastante
maravillosa pero es más maravillosa aún
cuando en lugar de theta lo reemplazamos
por pi entonces me quedarían que elevado
a la bim es igual al coseno de pi el
coste no de pi pues es lo mismo que
menos uno más y veces el seno de pim
pero el seno de pie 00 por y sebas
entonces me quedaría que elevado a la
epe es igual a menos uno lo cual de por
sí ya es bastante sorprendente pero si
nosotros sumamos uno de ambos lados de
la ecuación obtendría que elevado a la
ipi ya esto le sumamos uno es igual a
cero y esto sí está súper sorprendente
porque fíjate todos los números
especiales que conocemos
10 están relacionados directamente y es
que para mí estás igualdad más padre que
existen matemáticas y bueno ver de dónde
salía esto está en la lista de cal
pero lo que yo quiero que veas es que
aquí tenemos a un número súper especial
llamado en al cual se le llevamos a la
potencia imaginaria por pi ya esto le
sumamos 1 sería igual a 0 sin embargo
también estaría super duper que en lugar
de tener aquí un y tuviéramos un cierto
valor de tal manera que si yo tuviera
elevado a la i por ese valor me diera
igual a 1 digo aquí lo único que hice
por pasar el menos uno del otro lado
sumando sin embargo estaría también muy
padre que encontrará un valor que me
diera igual a 11 positivo
imagínate tendríamos que elevado a un
imaginario por otro número raro sería
igual a 1 esto sería sorprendente y
bueno este número mágico del cual te
quiero hablar no es un número mágico que
yo me inventen más bien no estoy tomando
los argumentos de estos dos autores
existe bastante gente que tiene el
movimiento tal y en el primero en el que
me baso es robert pala y en su artículo
pi está equivocado y su argumento no es
que esté mal calculado y no se refiere a
decir que no sea una medida angular de
la mitad de la circunferencia ni tampoco
dice que no sea 3.14 15 92 65 etcétera
etcétera sin embargo lo que dice es que
estamos poniendo mucha atención al
número equivocado
por otra parte mike el cartel en su
artículo el manifiesto de town que por
cierto todo esto se encuentra en línea
dice lo mismo y lo que ellos argumentan
es que existe un número tau y ellos
definen a todos de una manera muy
similar a pib con un pequeño cambio
ellos lo que dicen es que todo es por
definición la longitud de la
circunferencia entre el radio las bases
son las mismas pero en lugar de
multiplicar un medio por la longitud de
la circunferencia entre el radio lo cual
spin entonces ellos lo que se toman es
dos veces eso o dicho otra manera
dos veces pi tau es dos veces ping y
este número no es necesario que lo
memory cesc o bueno lo que es lo mismo
podemos multiplicar a dos por pi y me
daría a 6.28 3185 y sigue y sigue y
sigue y sigue y también es un número
irracional es decir que no cumple patrón
y tiene una expansión decimal infinita y
entonces seguramente vas a decir oye sal
que te traes contra pi pi es un valor
que ha trabajado durante muchos milenios
y además también lo costó
bastante aprenderme lo y además existen
toda esta teoría basándote en ella ahora
me lo cambias todo a tau que pasa sin
embargo la ella detalles un poco más
sencilla al aplicarlo a todo lo que
hemos aprendido de lo que es la idea de
piel y es justo por eso es lo que se
basa en ellos fíjate bien si nosotros
tenemos aquí ángulos en radiales
entonces lo que podemos hacer es verlos
en lugar de radiales los podemos ver en
tau radiales pero bueno de hecho antes
de ver los ángulos será muy bueno saber
qué es lo que pasa con la circunferencia
si nosotros tenemos la circunferencia en
teherán las circunferencias 2p y por
radio sin embargo si ahora no vemos en
términos de este nuevo número la
circunferencia sería mucho más fácil
verla como tau por el radio es decir en
lugar de estar pensando en multiplicar
por dos a pi y después por el radio es
más hace solamente multiplicarlo por tao
y la idea de los ángulos es muy parecida
si yo me tomo por ejemplo un cuarto de
la circunferencia entonces en lugar de
tener medios radiales y estar
multiplicando por dos y dividiendo por
dos es mucho más fácil tomar nota o
cuartos radiantes
es decir como nos tomamos solamente un
cuarto de la circunferencia entera
entonces el ángulo suspendido por el
arco que es un cuarto de longitud de
circunferencia pues está entre 4 así de
fácil y de sencillo y si nosotros
quisiéramos todo de la circunferencia
entera pues en lugar de tener dos
radiales tendríamos solamente tan
radiales y esta idea es un poco más
sencilla que todo lo que hemos visto lo
que hace te agüe simplificarnos un poco
las cosas porque entonces seríamos más
rápido si nosotros tuviéramos una
longitud de un arco de 10 veces tal pues
es muy fácil solamente tendremos que
darle 10 vueltas de la circunferencia
para obtener ese valor y de igual manera
si nosotros nos tomamos un tercio de la
circunferencia un quinto de la
circunferencia los ángulos que están
suspendidos serían un tercio de taura
dian es el quinto de tau radiales y así
sucesivamente y para empezar esa es la
razón es mucho más intuitivo y además
nos facilita mucho más las conversiones
en lugar de pensar en estas raras
conversiones multiplicando por dos y por
pi y etcétera etcétera
solamente nos fijamos en cuanto
recordemos de nuestra circunferencia así
tendríamos dos cuartos a uno medios
cuartos y para finalizar tau radiales
para darle la vuelta completa a mi
circunferencia el ángulo de dar una
vuelta completa a la circunferencia
estado radiales y bueno también un sirve
bastante si nosotros nos fijamos en la
gráfica y es igual al seno de un ángulo
porque en lugar de tener pi medios de
radiant espn medios de radiales
entonces yo voy a tener aumentos pues
para los pagos está out auto me estoy
equivocando si en lugar de tener pi
medios radiales yo voy a tener by
cuartos
yo voy a tener dos cuartos radiales av
cuartos radiales y en lugar de tener y
radiales voy a tener tan medios radiales
logra tener tres p medios radiales voy a
tener tres pi normal 3 está o tres
cuartos de tavo radiales en lugar de
tener dos piedras ya les voy a tener
está o radiales y es que esto es mucho
más intuitivo porque fíjate bien en este
punto ministrar yo fijando en qué es lo
que pasa en un cuarto de mi
circunferencia en un medio de mi
circunferencia en tres cuartos de una
circunferencia y en mi circunstancia
entera
por lo tanto es mucho más lógico que
estar dividiendo entre dos pero bueno
realmente el argumento más sólido que
tienen todas las personas que siguen el
manifiesto de tau es la fórmula de oyler
porque ellos dicen que se ve mucho más
hermosa esta fórmula impresionante de
las matemáticas entonces vamos a ver qué
es lo que pasa si metemos hasta aquí y
elevado al portal es lo mismo que el
coste no detalló más y veces el seno de
tau y cuántos esto bueno tomarme el
coche no es lo mismo que tomarme el goce
no de darle la vuelta entera a la
circunferencia y cuánto vale x cuando yo
le doy la vuelta entera la
circunferencia pues toma el valor de 1
por lo tanto este de aquí se me va a 1 y
si yo me tomo iii veces el seno de tau
pues es el valor de ella cuando yo le
doy una vuelta entre la circunferencia
lo cual es 0 y entonces me quedaría que
elevado a la mitad es igual a 1 y bueno
aquí te dejo para que tú pienses y que
tome esta decisión sobre cuál te gusta
más y además en cuál de estos dos
valores mágicos se te hace que todo se
ve mucho más estéticamente profundo